president
the president is here we are all here
the words of vladimir zelinski on night
two of the invasion cutting through
rumors that he had fled with a simple
selfie video from the streets of kiev as
russian forces approached the u.s
offered him support to escape zielinski
reportedly rejected it with these now
famous words i need ammunition not a
ride
history is full of leaders who run when
the odds are against them zielinski's
videos have instead reassured and
inspired his people as ukrainians dig in
and defy the russian army
[Music]
every citizen is president he says and a
warrior his leadership and courage
earning respect around the world he is
the embodiment of the courage of
ukrainian people
it was only three years ago zielinski
was a tv president playing for laughs as
a teacher who accidentally becomes
leader ukrainians who were fed up with
his pro-russian predecessor and with
corruption voted him in for real
a multi-talented comedian and actor with
a law degree from a russian-speaking
jewish family he won ukraine's dancing
with the stars
and even voiced the ukrainian version of
paddington it's interesting that the
paddington bear is fighting a big bear
ukrainian political analyst darisia
lucevic says zelinski has made mistakes
but his conviction is what matters now
at the time of existential threat like
ukraine is facing today they're all all
united across all languages political
parties communities you have absolute
cohesion zielinski says the enemy has
marked him as number one target but he
has refused to yield and rallied global
support in the process the funny man
who's proving to be nobody's fool
redmond shannon global news london